twenty years after we won the war  against the ominous we were no closer to  living together in peace  the building of a new home for the  ominous in London was supposed to be the  first step in improving human-robot  relation but it never had a chance the  Omni extremist group null sector  launched a surprise attack on Kings Road  hundreds were killed and thousands more  were displaced they took control  now they're hunting down the last of the  survivors it could be the beginning of a  new war between humans and ominous  unless we can stop them  commander Morrison has sent our strike  team to liberate the city it's my first  mission and the only way to save my home  I hope not  [Music]  you